[Music]
let's get another clip [ __ ] it
let's go on the next one let's just get
one more clip
so cybertruck always looks like cgi in
real life but that is not cgi that is an
actual cyber truck driving around
so i can't wait to have this baby in
production it's going to be epic
oh my god redditors when you leave
comments saying [ __ ] like that that's
what it sounds like in real life i can't
wait to put this baby in production and
see it in real life gonna be cool beans
how does anyone try to sit here and
convince us that this dude has charisma
i know he's like a cool he's not he
[ __ ] stinks he's in front of like 5
000 people and he sucks [ __ ] at it it's
not like steve ballmer that [ __ ]
gets up in front of a tech conference
and he's owning it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
or steve jobs cook yeah they own that
room elon is supposed to be this like
cool tony stark guy and he's getting up
there
all right sweating because he's getting
heckled yeah looks like cgi
it isn't everyone anyways it's gonna be
epic [ __ ] man that's a that's a cool
looking truck yeah what the hell crazy
man yeah reminds me of dune did you ever
see that yeah my samsung smart fridge
what's that on my cooler
i got a smart cooler i take it down to
the beach i'm still on the [ __ ] list
for that goddamn car you are yeah dude
you're never getting it i know you're
never getting i know it's a scam yeah i
know i've you know digested that at this
point that it's never happening
dude you do [ __ ] i will say this if it
did go into production it would be epic
can't wait to see one of these babies it
will be epic epic hack epic
sorry we got we got one more time stamp
at all it's crazy to just put on this
whole show of things you're never gonna
do i hope that [ __ ] car comes out i
do want it i wanna ev yeah i want i
wanna move on grivion it already is out
is it out already yes i barely see those
[ __ ] things i don't know i see i've
seen a handful in my neighborhood yeah
but here's the thing if i buy a rivien
how will elon benefit from that that's
true yeah yeah he won't and we want him
to have all the money
so
what's next
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna spill all
the beans right now
[Applause]
what i can say is we're going to move to
just truly massive scale
scale that
no company has uh ever actually scaled
that's all
um
scale i hate when people spill beans
perfectly good beans
and you're gonna spill them all over the
place
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what needs a massive scale
that dump truck on my buddy's new
girlfriend jesus christ [ __ ] she's her
own class of ford and that [ __ ] is a
550. her flatbed long as [ __ ]
cyber truck like in gta that has to
happen in order to transition the world
to sustainable energy so massive scale
full self-driving there's going to be
a dedicated robo taxi that's going to
look pretty yeah
fire
[Applause]
i think optimus wolf will obviate what
uh
it even means what an economy even means
so this has to be one of the worst
speeches i've ever seen ever dude he's
being talked over the whole time he's
bombing up there how dark is that
feeling he's just up there trying to do
his little school presentation and the
whole front row is like
[Applause]
this definitely went differently
[Laughter]
because he no you know what this is
there's like there are nerds in there
but there's actually a healthy mix of
regular people and that's what he's not
used to because when he does his little
presentations and stuff it's all dorks
that are like oh my god
how do you do what you do but now
there's a bunch of people in there who
have like crazy confidence you know that
like eat donuts off like the street he's
up there being like the next thing for
tesla he's like hey shut up man
hey man take a shot of this hey [ __ ]
that fireball take a shot of this he's
getting bullied yeah whatever guy we
should feel bad for him everyone
everyone go buy a tesla get on the
waitlist for a tesla poor guy or sign up
for twitter that helps him too
[Laughter]
yeah i was actually uh talking to my dad
i was asking why he hasn't uh rerouted
his social security to go to elon yet
because elon needs it yeah exactly how
else are we going to get these factories
for sustainable energy
that's what i'm saying preach oh we got
one more
first
tesla cars made in texas
oh no what is this
what's happening
[Music]
[Applause]
is he is supposed to be doing something
hell yeah bro
whole bunch of people that don't know
why they're there
[Applause]
yeah this is the exact same car that
we've seen five million times
yeah we've only made uh 20 cars in this
whole factory because uh
actually turns out that we need a lot of
coal to make these things you know like
one ev car uses a [ __ ] ton of coal yeah
like the offset is not good were we
talking about the giant like uh
propellers in palm springs no
apparently they
like
cost so much in like whatever they use
gas or whatever to first power it up to
get the spinning with the win yeah and
it takes like years and years to to make
that up i think i don't know if that's
true or not yeah i'm not sure either all
i know is that's a trump talking point
yeah exactly they just leave it trash
they leave the trash
that's good
i can't i got that just came out of
nowhere
i just remembered seeing him talking
he's like they leave his shoulder
everywhere it's awful